what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the banner of war yes we
are banner of war part three and this is
this is nuts this is one of those where
it's like beyond world breaker hulk
levels of incredible hulk it's kinda
nuts right it's absolutely ridiculous
here so for those of you guys who are
just joining us make sure you check the
playlist down in the description get
yourself caught up but getting into this
right so initially this talks about the
idea of quite literally iron man in his
celestial powered hulk buster suit
literally a gundam essentially facing
off against the hulk now here's the
thing about this the purpose of this
suit while it is capable or should be
capable of defeating the incredible hulk
its greater purpose is to basically
siphon the gamma energy off the hulk to
literally suck it off and then basically
de-power him now the reason why tony
stark goes this route is for a couple
different reasons one because we know
the incredible hulk is powered by gamma
radiation but two the world war hulk
event right that's literally one of the
things that tony stark did he had those
satellites that fired off and basically
de-powered the hulk reduced him back
down into his banner form although i
still argue that it was the fight with
uh hulk in the century that led to that
which was just a ridiculously amazing
fight but the cool thing about this is
that when it comes to iron man firing
this weapon off literally thor's just
watching this happen right thor's just
kind of like watching it unfold and and
that's literally done in kate says right
he says like the black hand of god lays
empty for the first time in millennia
it's knuckles unclenched as the power of
a celestial sun scorches its palm the
last remaining jackals and morbidly
curious ghouls of its quadrant squabble
and collect their unearthed winnings as
the bifrost scatters them to the winds
right so of course thor gets them out of
there and he says what comes next will
have no witnesses no watchers none save
thor the voice of his dead father
ringing in his ear and that's the cool
thing here right because literally the
fight between hulken and iron man is
pretty intense because iron man doesn't
fully understand what's going on here in
a couple different ways one he doesn't
fully understand what's going on
regarding the incredible hulk and the
titan hulk and two he doesn't fully
grasp the fact of the of the incredible
hulk and why it is that his weapon's not
working the way that it's supposed to
it's not siphoning off the gamma
radiation of the hulk the way that it's
supposed to now there are a couple ways
to approach this and this is one of the
ways in which marvel plays it fast and
loose with the incredible hulk and it's
why you kind of have to be a little bit
careful technically the incredible hulk
strength is limitless and one of the
things that was established in al
ewing's immortal hulk run is that with
bruce banner and like the green door and
all that kind of stuff the one below all
and so on basically bruce banner draws
on a limitless source of energy or the
incredible hulk does which is how it is
he's able to achieve unlimited strength
it's a bit of a deviation from like the
old school philosophies of the
incredible hulk which is that he's just
like literally his rage is a source of
power and it's unlimited right the
angrier he gets the stronger he gets and
while that still plays a role in it the
question you always had to ask is but
where's that power coming from it can't
simply just be rage that kind of seems
to be the question that's being answered
here and really was answered in al
ewing's run but again it still kind of
bridges the gap between those two
ideologies right those two philosophies
of how the incredible hulk always
function but one thing to keep in mind
is the titan hulk it's new here we've
never seen the titan hulk before in any
real form like we're seeing it and we
only really saw it at the end of the
last story arc and it's kind of making
its presence known to a degree here like
literally that's the the thing that goes
on like there's a point when iron man is
talking right talking to his his uh to
his ai but what he says is like this
suit's not working like it's supposed to
they should be able to safely apprehend
him he says don't get me wrong it's
doing its job but a this is an insane
amount of gamma radiation and two how is
he still standing shouldn't he be
smaller and the response of his ai is
incorrect right power levels are surging
gamma radiation is increasing so
literally the incredible hulk is getting
stronger as iron man is siphoning this
energy off of him it's crazy man it's
absolutely nuts now here's the crazy and
the the kind of nuts caveat to this he
does let off this blast of energy we
don't we see like the titan hulk form to
a degree but it doesn't fully manifest
right it's just kind of a small little
thing but even just this small amount of
energy that the titan hulk seemingly
lets off is enough to overpower iron
man's celestial powered suit which is
immense right i mean i don't know if
this suit is is capable of going toe to
toe with celestials but it is powered by
celestial energy so you could
conceivably create an argument here that
titan hulk is able to to overpower
celestials or at least challenge
celestials at that point it's a bit of a
stretch as little as that word means in
a story where a guy in a celestially
powered suit is fighting a green rage
monster while the whole thing's being
looked on by a god i mean the word
stretch doesn't really have meaning
when you're talking about the world of
comic books but still right like thor's
watching this whole thing go on and in
seeing iron man defeated by what is in
effect the titan hulk even though we
only get again a small glimpse of it
that's when thor steps in and thor's
like no like if you can hear me iron man
stand down right like this is bigger
than you and me and while technically it
really was iron man called here at the
end of the day this is much bigger and
it's actually bigger than thor thought
it was to a degree right it's like like
initially it was like okay like i can
just overpower banner and like that can
be it but it's a lot bigger than that
and both of them are realizing that and
that's one of the significant things
that that really has to be illustrated
here is that what they're saying here
and what's really being solidified is
that the amount of power the incredible
hulk is showing here is unlike anything
they've ever seen and they've seen it
right they've seen like world breaker
hulk and that kind of stuff i don't know
if thor technically has but like they've
seen this whole situation unfold right
they've seen this scenario take place
and because of that they're aware of how
powerful the incredible hull can be now
here's the real question that you have
to ask here is titan hulk this version
of the incredible hulk on par with like
the heart of the monster hulk because
that was the most powerful version of
the hulk that we had ever seen literally
he was breaking the dimension of uh of
dormammu right technically he was ruled
by umar but like he was he was literally
shattering the dark dimension like
cracking it because of how powerful he
was and neither iron man nor thor were
there for that event it was strictly
doctor strange right so we don't really
we don't really have a basis right to be
different if doctor strange was here and
it's like this is the most powerful
version of hulk i've ever seen and it's
like yep this is beyond uh this is
beyond heart of the monster hulk but at
the very least we know he's beyond world
breaker contextually and even just what
we're seeing in terms of the raw power
that he's putting off now the funny
thing is that odin is the one that's
like at least having his words and
chiming in with thor and basically
saying look like you have to let me get
involved here like i was in the mind of
banner if only momentarily banner's not
in control here right this is 100 the
hulk and in all honesty he's being
influenced by the titan hulk even if he
doesn't fully know one of the other
things to keep in mind too is the
persona of banner right the the the mind
of banner or at least his personality
essentially is watching all this unfold
as well and while he's not physically in
the real world he's basically back in
the mind of hulk but can essentially see
through the hulk's eyes basically and
that's one of the things that like he's
literally shouting to everybody no one
can hear him but he's like shouting at
everybody like you don't understand hulk
does not know this is not a uh this is
not a simulation that's the big caveat
here the incredible hulk thinks this is
a simulation right the incredible hulk
because he's so simple-minded remember
the personality of the hulk is used as
the engine of the incredible hulk body
but the personality of the hulk
basically fights an endless wave of
enemies and that's how banner that
personality is able to control the body
and amp up the strength and decrease the
strength but the personality of hulk
cannot differentiate between the two it
doesn't know that it's not in a
simulation as far as the incredible hulk
believes that that like thor and and
iron man all that kind of stuff they're
not real and so the incredible hulk does
not know that if he just totally
unleashes he'll kill him and he doesn't
know that they'll actually be dead in
the real world this is great because one
of the things this illustrates here is
that historically speaking the hulk has
always kind of held back to a degree and
that's true despite how angry the
incredible hulk got you can count on one
hand the number of times the incredible
hulk just threw friendships allies all
that kind of stuff through all alliances
to the wind and just one unbridled rage
there's the onslaught saga when the
banner personality was yanked out of the
mind of the incredible hulk by jean grey
in order to defeat onslaught they all
literally just stood out of his way
[Laughter]
because it was just it was nuts how
powerful he was there is of course the
world war hulk storyline and there's the
heart of the monster hulk storyline
there might be a couple more here and
there maybe but like there's very few
instances when the incredible hulk just
abandons any concept of friendship and
just total it's just pure unbridled rage
that almost never happens but that's
what's happening here right because he
doesn't know that they're real as far as
he's concerned they're not real and just
like all the other conflicts he had to
fight in the simulation he'll tear him
to pieces but his anger will just keep
getting getting higher and higher up now
of course this leads to odin basically
overriding thor and saying like enough
something has to be done here and
because the the hammer is possessed by
the spirit of odin it can essentially
act of its own volition and that's
exactly what it does right now this is
one of the best things about this is
because it's donnie kate setting
precedent here that up to this point in
time whenever it came to the hammer of
thor it was literally just an object
thor would use to achieve a goal right
he would just beat on things and that
was basically it when things started
shifting under the writing really of
jason aaron if you really want to trace
this back all the way back to the days
of thor god of thunder and really uh the
the stories of gore the god butcher
going into like original sin and all
that kind of stuff teasing the notion
that the hammer has a will of its own uh
really donnie cates was the one that
kind of amplified that with the actual
sentience the storm all that kind of
stuff like his run on thor what it
really did here is it set the precedent
for the idea that like the hammer being
possessed by a spirit or by uh by a
cosmic entity allowed the hammer to have
a will of its own that's just a stage
for odin possessing the hammer or you
know existing inside the hammer and
being able to use it for his own ends
there will be some who are against that
i think it's great i think it's a great
change to the thor mythos i love the
idea of mjolnir being anything other
than just an object thor uses to hit
stuff right like it's like when you look
at the owner for what it is that's
literally all it's ever been in mobile
comics a hammer the thor uses to hit
things because when you're a hammer
everything's a nail and that's it right
but so like give even just the hammer
itself almost its own kind of role it's
own personality in the comics it's a
great concept i love it right so again
you know that's one of the reasons why
i'm not necessarily adverse to change
the comics anymore because change is
great because sometimes cool things come
out of it but the thing about this is
that ultimately the hammer literally
odin as the hammer just flies into into
into the incredible hulk right now again
the enchantment all that kind of stuff
still remains and only the worthy could
lift the hammer so so the hulk's
ultimately pinned by it and so what you
get is this crazy moment when like
literally the hulk's pinned down to the
ground and uses i-beams to like destroy
this physical manifestation of odin and
that's when iron man's like okay i don't
know what's going on here right now but
this is not the hulk that i remember the
hulk that i remember is the one who just
yells hulk smash he beats some stuff up
we have to like corral him in right reel
him in we have to calm him down and then
like business as usual like i've never
seen the hulk shoot freaking lasers out
of his freaking eyes
right like just straight up dr evil
right just freaking laser beams i have
never seen that happen right like i've
never seen that take place i mean that's
one of the things that's going on here
right like the incredible hulk whether
or not these powers will become
mainstays i don't know but the reality
of the reality of this is that with the
incredible hulk getting so enraged to
getting so mad getting so angry at the
fact that he quite literally can't lift
himself because of the hammer that all
this gamma radiation this surge if
you've noticed it's just been building
up and building up and building up and
so ultimately the exact thing that we
would expect to happen happens that he
just detonates right it's just literally
this gamma bomb that just explodes and
so in effect iron man is seemingly the
only one left standing and once of
course he gets out of his suit and he
starts looking around and like is his
space suit right his normal iron man
garb if you want to call it that he
notices a kind of shadow that's out
there and so he's like okay did we know
that the incredible hulk could do that
did we know that he could basically just
unleash huge amounts of gamma radiation
in the form of an explosion and the
answer to that question is no that seems
like a pretty new thing to have i mean
technically some immortal hulk stuff
goes in there but it's a relatively new
thing to the thor mythos and so in the
end the statement that's made by stark's
ai is the reason why he wasn't
incinerated like any normal human being
would be is because he was protected by
the celestial suit of armor that he had
and so then he asked the question he's
like okay so you're saying that if a
human was caught in this blast would
they end up basically becoming like an
incredible hulk because what what we
witnessed is just a gamma a gamma bomb
right it's like is that would that be
the case and the response of this ai is
no that person would be incinerated so
then he asked the question okay so what
if it wasn't a person who was caught
like a normal human who was caught in
this gamma bomb explosion god is so good
what if what if it wasn't a human who
was caught in this gamma bomb explosion
because it was equivalent to like 3 000
gamma bombs what if it was like i mean
just for shits and giggles hypotheticals
what if it was a god and that's when you
end up finding out thor was caught in
the blast thor was hit with the power of
3 000 gamma bombs and what this did is
it turned thor into a hulk so literally
he's just like thor
smash i gotta say man this story is
amazing
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace